as many of you know
the uh logo that i'm using that i've
been using for the past i guess four
years maybe was it five years now uh
that logo will soon be going away i i
have had another logo design which i'll
present to you very soon those that
follow me on patreon i've already seen
it and gotten a sense of what it means
but i thought that before we say goodbye
to the old image that it would be a good
idea to do an interpretation of it and
that interpretation will not of course
just be about my logo but will help you
get some insight into the very story of
creation and also how christian art
works and how iconography kind of brings
elements together spatially in order to
show you some of the patterns that are
hidden in the stories
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
so this image is taken from a missile it
is of course the six days of creation
but it is taken from a german missile
called the stamheim missile you can see
it here
in its totality of course in the center
are the six days but then
at the top of the image we see christ
who's at the origin of the world
we see two angels next to him that are
you know somewhat like the two angels
that are
the angels that are guarding paradise or
the angels that are at the top of the
ark of the covenant kind of bringing all
of those images together i've talked
about in other talks before how you
often have these two angels at the top
of ancient images to kind of represent
this um
this idea of the two chair of that are
guarding or that are
that are hiding or revealing the uh the
mystery
so the bottom of the image we also have
uh a few more things going on we have
adam and eve being chased from paradise
here where you can see eve is covering
herself with a
fig leaf and you see the angel holding
the flaming sword
over here
and then you have of course the result
of the fall which is kane killing abel
here at the on the on the right side
and so you know you have the cherub
which is represented more like a serif
but it that those things get a little
they get fused together in christian art
you have the cherubs
that are guarding the garden but that
are also at the top of the ark of the
covenant then you have the flaming sword
that is here chasing adam and eve out of
the garden and so you can get a sense of
this is really this a cosmic image of
how all of this is coming together at
the bottom of the image we also have
king david
who is holding a psalm
and the psalm i forget exactly what the
the phrasing but it's something like you
know all the works that you have done oh
god something like that like all of your
creation of god and so in in the very
structure of the entire image now you
have of course the creation here in the
middle we have christ as the origin of
creation above with a little dome here
and so you all even get a sense of
heaven which is above
and then
the the cherub the creation and at the
bottom you have creation answering or
creation worshipping you have the answer
from above
which is part of the story of creation
itself which we've talked about before
so you have a declaration of creation
from above and an answer of worship and
of recognition from below so that's the
base that's the total image of course
that is not in my logo i thought you
would might want to know a little bit
what is going on
and so
this image is an image which was made by
someone named wesley swank who is part
of the
the symbolic world facebook group very
active member very interesting member
and he was the first one to kind of work
it out and do the translation of all the
different parts in latin which is what
is written in the text so in the the
transversals you have of course all the
days which are
in the transversals you have all the
days which are written so first day
second day third day fourth day fifth
sixth day
and then in the circles you have all the
uh the um
the verses that are compressed and
written down
and so i made a black and white version
of this
which i used in some of the images that
i sell and some of the t-shirts that i
make and in this you will see
the the whole thing and you see each day
and a basic translation it's not exactly
the translation that wesley did i wanted
you know his was very literal literal
very direct i wanted it to be a little
more
let's say in english a little more
cohesive
so when we look at the way that it's
structured you'll get a sense of
how all of these images are related so
on in the first day it says god said let
there be light and there was light and
the second day
let there be a firmament in the midst of
the waters
third day let the earth bring forth
vegetation that yields seed
fourth day let there be lights in the
firmament of the heavens
fifth day let water swarm with life and
let birds fly above
and then of course sixth they let the
earth bring forth cattle and beast in
kind and the sixth day opens up you can
see it here where it opens up into
the central image which is the creation
of man
and what's interesting about the way
that it opens up into the center is that
it is on the sixth day the creation of
man but it also becomes like the seventh
image and so it's very particular it's
very particular it's very interesting
because of course the seventh day is the
day of rest the day that god rested and
so here there's a
there's a re
let's say a relationship which brings
which is brought about which is
surprising because of the way it's
represented in space which is that in
the seventh image which is still on the
sixth day nonetheless hints at the
seventh day or at the day of rest
where adam is resting but then here in
this day in this rest
eve is being created uh out of atom so
let's look at the way that is structured
the the artist the way that they
structured it by doing it in a circle
this way and by having the circle
separated into six
sections he is
really bringing about some very
fascinating patterns and those patterns
appear mostly
in how each image
is across from another image
and so the image in the the top here is
across from the one diagonally here and
what it does is it shows you a
relationship
between the the days and how they end up
how the first three days have a certain
pattern the second three days fractally
represent or fractally uh reproduce
the pattern that was there in the first
three days
and so you have it says god said let
there be light and there was light in
the very first day
and then in the
the day that it's across it the fourth
day
it says
let the lights in the let there be
lights in the firmament of the heavens
and so it's also light again but now
it's the light that are in this the
second heaven so light in the spiritual
light or like very the first light out
here and then second light over here
which would be something like the light
in the firmament and so
on the second day now we continue the we
continue the same question
it says let there be a firmament in the
midst of the waters and so you have the
heaven and the waters below the second
heaven and the second waters
and down here on day five then you have
the creation of the animals that will
fill that space so you can understand it
that
up here is basically the
let's say the space itself or the the
principles themselves and then below are
the things that fill it so above you
have the firmament and the waters and
below you have
let the the water swarm with life and
the birds fly above so you have that
which fills the that which is below
which are the fish and that which fills
that which is above which are the which
is in the heavens
and you see of course the same thing
happened on the third day which is that
it says let the earth bring forth
vegetation that that yields seed and so
you have a sense of the earth
the earth and its plants but then across
from it now you have the earth and its
animals the animals that exist on that
earth and so there's an interesting
relationship which happens which shows
you like this fractal pattern that is
going on in the six days of creation all
across from each other it's interesting
that this part here you know this the
plants that come about they come about
before even the lights in the heaven and
so there are all these relationships
going on that are very fascinating to to
see so interestingly enough one of the
things that are that is missing in this
image is of course that which comes
before the first day or that which comes
in the beginning
and this in the beginning part i think
is fair to say that it is captured
by
the first the image the full image in
the samhain missile which is you see
let's say outside of the six days you
see christ above as the origin of all
things and then below the answer of
earth the worship of of the
of that which is below the the the first
let's say heaven and earth represented
that way that's what it seems to me at
least
but then it is brought into the image
let's say more subtly
by what is written around the uh the
creation of adam and eve because it says
so god created man in his own image in
the image of god he created him
male and female he created them
so by making god by making man in his
image this of course accounts for why
man is at the center of all of creation
man is that which all creation is kind
of leading towards the center in the
sense of also the reason for creation
but then also you know we've talked
about this to a certain extent how there
is a kind of mysterious way in which man
is there already at the outset of
creation we see that especially in the
second creation narrative
um
but then it also repeats the pattern of
the in the beginning which is that it
says god he created male and female he
created them so by creating them uh male
and female you get a sense in which
uh
the act of creation itself and so this
is something that i've been i wondered
quite a bit why is it that the image
shows eve coming out of adam i always
kind of wondered why was this image that
they had chosen to put in there because
it's not necessarily the most
traditional version of the creation of
of man usually the most traditional
virgin just shows uh christ sitting on
the cosmos and then you know with his
hand blessing and you see adam who is
there in front of him
but i think the reason why they put this
version is because they wanted to imply
the act of creation itself and they also
wanted to imply male and female together
as being this microcosm of all of
creation
that's my at least my impression of why
they wanted to do it this way and
but at least for us what's interesting
at least for me what was interesting
about this image and one of the reasons
why i chose it was because if you've
noticed if you've seen it in my videos i
do end up talking quite a bit about the
power and the importance of feminine
symbolism
in in the bible in the world you know
all over the place uh also talking about
how feminine symbolism in my opinion has
been quite
distorted and in a certain manner
there's a lack of respect or a lack of
love in the contemporary world
for the feminine symbolism which is
which is disguised as feminism actually
but is actually just a kind of fetish
fetishization of male power and of
masculinity and a kind of pushing aside
or
a a desire to get rid of all the uh the
powerful and beautiful imagery in
feminine symbolism so i thought that it
also made sense to have this particular
image as the one that represents my
videos
just because i knew that this is
something that i would be talking about
quite a bit
and so i hope that this gives you a good
idea of what is going on of why i chose
this image for the symbolic world it has
served me very well i love it very much
but it also is
it is very complicated and very complex
and it kind of lacks the simplicity of a
of a logo and so very soon i will be
presenting you with my new logo as
finally my website which i started last
year and then
that whole process collapsed i had to
change the people that were making the
website
um and it was very it was a lot of
trouble and then got as god's dog was
kind of coming into play i had to put
that aside for a while but now i'm back
on track with the website and hopefully
in the next few months it will appear
with all the things that i wanted in
there including the forums which are
important to me to move away from
from control by the social media company
so we can have a space of our own where
we can discuss all these things
and the website is done by someone who's
an expert on security and is working
with several
several servers and people that are
let's say working towards resisting what
is going on and avoiding to get shut
down uh easily by the government of
course they can always do it if they
want to but at least to make it
as hard as possible to shut you down as
things move into more and more crazy
spaces so i hope you enjoyed this
interpretation of the symbolism of my
logo and looking forward to present the
new logo to you very soon
as you know the symbolic world is not
just a bunch of videos on youtube we are
also a podcast which you can find on
your
usual podcast platform but we also have
a website with a blog and several very
interesting articles by very intelligent
people that have been thinking about
symbolism on all kinds of subjects we
also have eclipse channel a facebook
group you know there's a whole lot of
ways that you can get more involved in
the exploration and the discussion of
symbolism don't forget that my brother
matsuya wrote a book called the language
of creation which is a very powerful
synthesis of a lot of the ideas that
explore and so please go ahead and
explore this world you can also
participate by you know buying things
that i've designed t-shirts with
different designs on them and you can
also support this podcast and these
videos through paypal or through patreon
everybody who supports me has access to
an extra video a month and there are
also all kinds of other goodies and
tiers that you can get involved with so
everybody thank you again and uh thank
you for your support